so they're doing whatever right so I
can't be like this I don't know what's
happening that he already move when he
brought his foot back right I'm already
moving this way so let's do again
there's a lot of pre-movement a lot of
pre movement and there's also a lot of
pay attention to the opening yes okay so
I'm not going like this
right a lot of preo right
lot of pre
movement pre movement all right every
time
pre
movement move
it move
it
move moov
moving now I like this
so
boom
boom look for the openings and add your
pre
movement
e
e e
so if I do keyan right and you go like
this and I don't know what you think
that is but there should be a a
disturbance of this
balance right at contact okay so now
we're
ballistic go it doesn't matter that's
not
it notice this this isn't it right
that that's only that if he takes one
step right then I can pull him off down
but in this situation he's Dynamic so
he's just walking through you see and I
just have a guy standing
up so I'm not deviating for the sake of
deviation I'm not that's not why make a
principle out of it just say get out of
the
way then secondly same thing I'm not
blocking just for deflection
again there's no need for a principle if
you're just going to say stop it from
hitting you okay so my movement has to
do things to
him and that is achieved through the yin
space the yin space so I let him
in that that same movement is what's
allowing me to hit him that you saw in
the last break right right so as
supposed to go like
this like that no the movement is here
boom and you
hit even when I don't hit right so again
right boom keep him going forward you
see and he hits the
forearm if I need help boom
hit but not this
be
closer boom whatever doesn't work that's
your TMI because you'll have a Yin space
so he has a lot of balance okay cool
boom that's your Yin
space but the art
move move and let through move and let
through you can mix it up
right move
don't stop
him you're stabilizing
him keep him
going he's right here look look so you
can see the
force back again to same strike yog in
so you see right here he keeps going on
the circle and he's starting this
balance going that's the deviation Boom
for the strike
it's all right there
boom okay put it all together
go
e e
okay so your your fight is much closer
so if we do to D you see let's just look
at chest level now put your hands up you
see
you see where we're at you're trying to
do your defenses way back here okay so I
got I'm going to be close I'm going to
have my outer riming goal okay I'm going
to have my pre-movement this is about
how do I get the yin space because your
your Yin space concept he goes to strike
is to
move you have to get him to to want to
hit
you you see and then I'm going to get
get closer to so he falls into
itom not out
here
close
close so a lot of movement I'm need to
leave
out
again you guys see how I'm doing that so
uh basically your internal movement as
you as you're moving energy inside you
can make it grosser movement do you
understand so all the belly dancing and
stuff like that that's what I'm that's
what I'm using I'm not belly dancing but
I'll segment my body as I need
to but I'm
calm
Calm if I move my M my SP find you're
going to in uh cause him to fill that
right so when we're here it's like oh
he's going to get that you see that so
boom
out so I'm just doing that with my guard
[Music]
we
movement okay let's try it
again
e
e e